all right we already knew that lines B
and D should be in the final list since
they were in both files before we didn't
really know whether it's the lines had
been there at to be any other day or
whether Jake and Rachel had both added
them but now we know it was already
there now let's look at a at the
beginning of the day line a was present
Rachel's file still contains it so she
didn't do anything with it but Jake's
file doesn't contain it that means that
he removed line a so we don't want it in
the final file now let's look at C C
doesn't appear in the original and Jake
doesn't have it either but Rachel does
since it wasn't there to begin with we
know that she added it so it should be
in the file the same thing goes for e
since it's not in the original but Jake
has it we do run it in the final file